hey what's going on man why you have
your hat
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday
March 6th
2023.
what's going on how why yeah
um
you know what's weird I was writing
something in the the song and not the
song the [__] word ended in t-i-o-n
and I just never got this that song out
of my head
was on the electric company t i o and
Shawn
t i o n
cha cha cha
Cha Cha Cha that has been in my head for
50 [__] years and I finally decided
to look it up and listen you think I'm
lying
I oh man
[Music]
t-i-o-n put a dash between all those
letters
and uh put electric company after that
you'll find it
uploaded by Charles Bradley II thank you
for doing that t and you know what's
funny is that no comments no one has
commented on these comments don't dis
activate oh he deactivated the [__]
it has 23 900
[__] uh views
that means twenty three thousand fifty
something year olds went had that
[__] song in their head and they're
like I wonder if somebody opened it uh
uploaded it
did somebody open it up on that internet
did somebody upload it
t-o-wan
that [__] it's got a
it's got a Groove to it right it's all
real people playing on it
you know some chick with a big ass and a
tambourine somewhere there's always
there was always some chicken a big ass
and a [__] tambourine back then you
know doing that thing [__]
head side to side and coming up on their
hand and then down on a [__] sort of
a hit but also her ass but it was mostly
your hip so they could still show it on
CBS NBC or ABC
um you wouldn't know it but I'm not
drinking coffee
and I got energy
yourselves A New Kind [__] shut it
um yeah I've been working out old Billy
beefcake
um the last like two months straight
I've been working out I've been doing
what I need to do I've been doing uh you
know what I did I bought that uh Suzanne
Summers [__] Thigh Master and I've
just been doing that and I got to tell
you something I have some shapely pasty
freckled thighs right now and I'm very
happy with them
and uh I probably I'm not supposed to
say this but I'm gonna say it they're
actually rebooting Charlie's Angels and
Charlie is going to be played by
Charlize Theron
and and then the three checks are gonna
be dudes they're totally rebooting it
they're putting the woman
in the power position plus she doesn't
have time to do the show so she just
wants to do the voiceover
um
I get to be uh whoever has the Mustang
too that's the one I'm gonna be
you know it's funny you could probably
pitch that show and actually get it made
you know as long as you had Charlize
attached this [__] goddamn hate in
this place I swear to God
or once it [__] heats up then it goes
all the way down because I don't know
how to shut that other thing off all of
this stuff all of this stuff would
[__] drives me nuts about it
is I know it's like a simple solution it
was like the last time I was [__]
doing my podcast and I was [__]
annoyed
you know
my uh the great Andrew femalis was able
to talk me off the [__] ledge
like one of those guys back in the day
with the bullhorns did that actually
exist
every time there was a cop show they
always had a potential jumper
you know that was just to fill up time
like Jesus Christ I mean they used to do
like [__] 30 episodes hour long
how do we fill it up that's what kills
me about those Law and Order shows how
do they keep [__]
how do they keep coming up with ideas
there's only so many crimes those
[__] shows have been on for 30 years
I don't know how they I just thought it
just blows my [__] with this God
there's another Lasher
and uh he's got crack 2.0
and he's dealing it in the city
we this guys that have been on that show
longer than an actual police career
[Laughter]
it's like the new Mash remember like
mash was was longer than the actual
[__] war no bill we don't remember
mash it went off the air 40 years ago
[Music]
oh
that's gonna be in your [__] head
it's the end of pollution
they even knew it back then I've never
had a teacher in first grade and she
says to me she says to me red you with
the orange hair and no hope
um all hope gone already
you look like a future comedian to me
they have freckles
she goes look up at the sky look how
blue that sky is there might be a day
when that doesn't happen anymore she
said that to me and I'm just she didn't
really say to me she said it to the
whole class but I you know like Jordan I
took it personal
I thought she was talking to me and I
was thinking like well I hope the blue
skies don't go away oh Little Billy
freckles was looking up at the [__]
sky in the early 70s thinking someday
there'd be no Blue Sky you know
you know what kills me is they already
[__] knew that [__] they knew about
global warming and all that in the late
1950s and they're still not doing [__]
about there was some lady
lady
I [__] you and then I didn't call you
cause I was on cocaine
I woke up I missed you and I decided to
call is that how the lyrics go to that's
I never heard that whole song
lady
the sensitive side of Kenny Rogers when
he's not killing the world with his
Fried Chicken he kind of really was the
real Colonel Sanders huh you know that's
how he died
he was eating his uncle he ate the last
bucket of Kenny Rogers chicken
[Music]
I'm sorry
what you think I don't have the Gambler
on my phone everybody does
you got to know when to hold them no way
to fold up though when to walk away and
nowhere to run
you never shaved your beard and keep
that [__] long hair and don't you
[__] diet or all the country folks
will know you're a phony do you guys
believe in that [__] where like if a man
dyes his hair you can't trust him I
remember reading that a long time ago if
guy dies his hair you can't trust him
um
I think I got that solved
um anyway this is the podcast if you're
new to it welcome
thanks for tuning in what are you doing
huh you on an elliptical
all right you can do it this guy kept
yelling at the other night last night I
had to fight one of the best
um times at a sporting event I've had in
years I went to a college basketball
game yes I did
yes I did
whatever those [__] calls call it
sounds so like that right
I went to USC
I went to uh USC versus Arizona I don't
know why I'm so [__] amped up I just
worked out too
probably the endorphins you know when
you work out you're not a doctor shut up
these [__] people these Instagram
doctors shut your [__] goddamn pie
holes
Instagram doctors and life coaches you
know
just stick them in a car
you know one of those self-driving cars
and just send it right off the end of
the pier
no then you would be polluting the ocean
tea oh and
um I feel like I'm extra annoying this
week I'm so I feel like anybody who has
this on speaker right now their wife or
girlfriend is like oh my God how can you
lift this guy he said [__] a net
ah pipe down lady go make them a
sandwich
anyway I'm kidding
sober Bill the first if you if you're
new to the podcast the first 10 days of
every month I don't do [__] I just shut
it off you know
that includes any emotion I have for
people around me no I I no coffee no
[__] cigars no sugar
and um
I shut it
the [__] down I just flipped the switch
that's it I'm like that guy in Sharky's
Machine right I just bring the antenna
down
and I swear to God like he was still
[__] looking at me and I walked right
out the goddamn room improvising
improvising
um
anyway
I've been doing really good at that and
last night I went to like as I mentioned
like as I mentioned like I mentioned
I went to uh
USC uh versus Arizona basketball game
and it was like oh my God this is the
this is the sporting experience that I
remembered
there wasn't a DJ playing music
throughout like while they were playing
it was amazing and he was really like
didn't interfere with the game in the
second half I felt like he was trying to
get the crowd amped up and I think more
more than even just how loud they play
and how much they they're playing while
the game is going on
um
what really drives me up the [__]
wall is there they don't play to what's
going on in the game
the whole time they're acting like in
two minutes they're playing music like
in two minutes your team's gonna win the
championship and if you're watching an
exciting game I guess that works but
when you're watching a dog [__] game
you know and both teams aren't playing
well I mean they played for five minutes
and the score was like four to four I
mean it was sloppy it ended up being a
great game but it was sloppy I'll tell
you right now
it was a sloppy ass [__] game and the
DJ's going everybody clap your hands
it's like buddy I'm not clapping for
this [__] all right I'm I'm looking at
both head coaches trying to I'm trying
to bet who's gonna throw a clipboard
first right but anyway uh fortunately
the DJ was cool
he underplayed
um I like the first half better than the
second half second half I thought you
know every [__] stop at your play
they still have to go to some jerk off
in the [__] stance
it's like I didn't come here to see that
um but it was way better than when I
went to the Lakers Milwaukee Bucks where
the DJ played at like on 11 for the
entire game and uh I'm kind of sold on
college basketball I absolutely [__]
loved it and
um I'd never been to that Arena it was
fantastic perfect size 10 000 seat Arena
not a bad seat in the [__] house
great people uh I saw a great game came
right down to the last possession they
um
I can't remember if you would see one by
two or three
think if the guy hit the three-pointer
it would have gone into overtime but it
was uh
yeah it was a [__] great time
although we did have to change our seats
you know
I don't want to body shame anybody but
like we sat down in the [__] body
odor I swear to God it was like it
smelled like a boxing gym
right and I was just like who the [__] I
thought it was my buddy I went with I
was like Jesus Christ
never known him to smell like it just
smelled like a dude you just thought
there's some dude in here
that just got done [__] you know he
went the full 15 not 12 went 15 [__]
rounds
and it ended up being the lady in front
of us who wasn't even wearing a shirt
really it was like a spaghetti strap
half shirt
with her pits out and God damn am I
happy they didn't do the [__] wave at
any point during that game it was so bad
for the second half we sat like 30 rows
back we found some empty seats hahaha
there's just no way to tell a woman that
she stinks
you know what I mean I'm not saying you
stink at what you do but God damn it
lady God damn it I mean if you're not
gonna wear deodorant I get it you don't
want to get Alzheimer's later on in life
but have a [__] hat and put on a
shirt with some sleeves
you know
uh
it was [__]
I mean I look like Maverick and Top Gun
when he has that [__] oxygen mess I
just have my t-shirt up over my nose it
was [__]
it was yeah
it was like spend a night in jail
it was just there it was almost visible
that Bo
um
I wonder what what you would be what
would happen if you actually had like
that old school deodorant spray
and uh she was a little thing too so she
kind of had her arms like
at 90 degrees on the [__] armrests or
little elbows could reach the armrest
which of course opened the pits
and you know
it was like she was marking her
territory Bill you're gonna get off the
subject I'm not I smelt it for [__]
20 College minutes
um
foreign
that's what's funny about when you go to
see something live there's always going
to be something I literally sat down I
was like oh my God they got the school
banned they got the student section
there's that excitement there's youth
man they got hope their whole lives are
ahead of them they're [__] day and
and they studied in high school or or
their parents photoshopped their heads
onto somebody rowing a boat but they're
there man at one of the top universities
and they know that this is the best four
[__] years of their goddamn life and
that energy is there and you sit down
you're like oh my God these are great
seats and what always happens the
universe has to balance it out
a cute little [__]
so and so in front of us couldn't have
weighed more than 80 [__] pounds with
Bo that could have knocked over a
[__] horse
that's just how it works
if that place was a dump and the band
wasn't there and it absolutely sucked it
would have smelled like Febreze in there
which makes no sense because it's a dump
you know what I mean something would
happen they would have like the best
[__] hot dog you ever had there's
always going to be something to [__]
balance it out
um
by the way I watched another movie I'm
trying to watch all the Oscar uh
nominated movies
uh
uh so I did I mention I saw triangle is
sadness
uh Woody Harrelson one of my favorites
just [__] kills it all the time and I
I wish I knew the actor's name the guy
who plays he plays this Russian
billionaire and he is just the the two
of them
together uh just [__] amazing I would
I would go see it again just to watch
that uh
that interaction and also like
this I don't want to this there's
another scene too that's there's that
bunch of scenes [__] great movie all
right two freckled thumbs up go see that
at the cinema right and then I saw uh
I saw uh Kate Blanchett I think it's
called tar it's spelled t-a-r but it has
one of those little [__] things on
top of it so I don't know if it's t-a-r
but um I watched that and
um
it made me want to quit Show Business
I was just like how the [__] do you
write us this somebody wrote all of that
she memorized all of that like it's just
unbelie unbelievable [__] movie
um
I don't know how to talk about movies
without ruining them
um she's always amazing
she's always amazing but the [__]
writing in that movie God damn
I was just trying to picture it on the
page
like how long is this [__] scene and
it's and it's not dying it's it's
soaring it was amazing so I've seen two
great movies I want to see that um
that Irish one that Colin Farrell's in I
want to see All Quiet on the Western
Front
um what else is there
uh women are talking
I could guarantee you Nia's not gonna
watch that with me I can guarant [__]
T you that one
um
anyway uh I gotta watch Chris Rock's new
special
I was at the uh I was at the game the
night his uh
his special was uh he did it live and I
heard nothing but rave reviews from
every comic
that I love so I gotta check that out
um
it's on Netflix now streaming now he did
it live which I think is [__]
the balls that that takes and then also
you know what's amazing about that no
editing it's over
you do it it's done there you go
you don't have to do that awful thing
where you hey now we're gonna sit down
and watch an hour and 10 minutes of you
I'm sure you're making good decisions no
you should you should look at it no no
no we want we're very proud no it's good
it's good you should sit down I don't
want to watch it no but you have to
have to you have to sit down and you
have to watch this book
he doesn't have to do any of that which
I'm I'm like a lady I'm envious of that
envious of that um
anyways and it's always great for stand
up
one of the greatest of all time comes
out and puts a [__]
you know giant special out there that
everybody [__] loves that so that's
always that's good for everybody it's
good for everybody
what's that what's that thing back in
the day
thanks to you it works for all of us the
United Way
no that sounds too [__] yeah thanks
to you everything's [__] up or maybe
it's the my tone let me try to do a
better tone
thanks to you it works for all of us
the United Way
wow who the [__] was that guy is
anywhere supposed to be for all the
[__] [__] happening oh my God I
gotta do that guy
if I did if I acted like that which is
what my wife thinks she wants me to be
like if I just acted like that around
the house that would just [__] freak
her out
good morning honey
would you like some eggs
she would immediately be like what are
you doing
stop doing that you're freaking me out
then I go back to how I am and then
she'd be like you need to stop doing
that
um why do I always act like she's a pain
in the ass she isn't she's the best
[__] thing that ever happened to me
all right
maybe I'm just scared of losing you
um all right let's get to the uh why did
I close this [__] thing
Oh Billy crack corn and I don't care
so yeah so I've been working out you
know doing it all natural man I'm gonna
do it all natural and then I'm just
gonna I'm gonna take some [__] Lyle
Alzado level steroids
and just just I'm gonna get one of these
[__] Marvel movies
it's got to be a superhero left huh do
you have albino man why didn't they give
it to a real albino
no I understand I understand that he's a
Ginger he's almost there but still
all that makeup they had to use to paint
out his freckles just think when he
washes it off in the shower what that
does to the environment
um
how about the Bruins
they won like eight or nine in a row and
I'm missing all of it I'm just too
[__] busy because uh you know what
cause I'm a good father how about that
before you say I don't care anymore
um my son wants to play drums every day
that is truck that is truck
so I can do that every day every day he
plays drums and then I give him a ride
in my truck and my daughter out of
nowhere told me that she wants to be an
artist and now she's drawing every day
she loves to read
it's uh
it's amazing it's amazing
um
anyway
um yeah Bruins beat the Rangers
um I watched the second period of that
game
um range is very underrated like great
uniforms I like those red pants who the
[__] would ever think you'd have red
pants with the blue who would put blue
and red together
and those colors you wouldn't think it
looks good but it looks great it's a
classic uniform and you know I know they
[__] with it one time
where they sort of had like uh I always
thought that one with like when they had
the Statue of Liberty's face on it for
some reason it reminded me of Tina
Turner in uh in that movie Tommy
you know when he's [__] tripping on
acid or something and she's [__]
yelling in his face and [__]
laughs
I don't know why
um
anyway
where am I going here from here uh yeah
I've been playing a lot of drums because
my son goes out there every day I'm like
yeah man I gotta [__] I gotta play
some more this kid's gonna catch up
and pass me so uh been playing a bunch
of drums to the point you know I started
[__] around you know every once in a
while a buddy of mine has an album he's
putting out and I listened to it and was
[__] amazing and it made me want to
play some more double bass
because he had some uh like you know
some Vinnie Paul kind of those roughs
into the singles
I was like I want to do that I want to
go home sorry
um
but I had a good time with that oh I got
to tell you this [__] thing I saw the
other day right
so uh
I don't know what the [__] I was doing I
drove by this coffee shop and I see this
big long [__] line big long [__] I
don't know why I said it like that big
long [__] line right down the street
and all I was thinking was like ah thank
God I'm not drinking coffee this time of
the month or I'd be standing in that
line
you know
so why does it [__] do that how do I
shut it off and get it to stop [__]
doing that every time I have a I have a
I'm sure it's in the settings go into
settings
General click on General
what kind of Mac do you have I don't
know
an obsolete one
I know I don't you know I don't know why
they do that well why would you work for
the country the country why would you
work for the company then
if you know that's what they do
you know last time I did the podcast I
talked about how I was going to get rid
of all my cigars and all these [__]
books on my bookshelf that I'm done and
I'm never going to look back at and I
haven't done anything but I'm gonna do
it
I said I was gonna do it God damn it I'm
gonna do it does anybody want a I have a
uh
Rosetta Stone is there anybody out there
over the age of 50 and still has a uh
what is that a hard drive oh is this
[__] thing just gonna ring the whole
time you [__]
oh God
no no no no no this is the new me okay
there has to be a way to shut this off
let's let's see if I can do it right in
front of you guys right in front of you
on this thing all right okay so I went
into settings what would you say I would
click on desktop doc displays wallpaper
screens save your battery lock anything
is there is there something I can click
on that says sounds
annoying sounds let's go into General
the general oh those are the worst
commercials on the [__] internet
about software storage airdrop login
times language daytime sharing time
machine I got a time machine on this
[__] thing transfer or reset startup
disk
yeah I don't know how to do this
screen saver battery wallpaper
none of this looks like the answer
password internet game center
this there's so many Nerds out there
right now just going wallpaper going to
the wallpaper section desktop and Doc
okay portion of the screen minimize
minimize any menu bar
I'm sure I could Google it
yeah you know what I'll Google it um
anyway
get back
so I'm driving down the street there's
this big long line of [__] people
just standing there waiting to get their
fix
you know that Bean Juice right
you walk in you smell it
wakes up a little bit
you know maybe you're excited to be
woken up
maybe you don't really want to be woken
up
you know the people who don't drink
coffee is it because they're so sad
they don't want to be awake during the
day is that what it is I don't notice
maybe they just take naps
um anyway
400th time trying to tell a story I'm
driving up the street this big long line
at the uh
the The Coffee Joint
and as I go by I see this guy I don't
know if he was drinking coffee or
waiting let's just say he had his coffee
he had a coffee in his hand and he's
looking at his phone
all right and up top
he you know he looked like he worked for
the town
big [__] head
full head of that [__] hair you know
we just like you don't even need that
hair you're not in Show Business you're
not in politics
right
you're not the town quarterback you work
for the [__] you ever see like homeless
people homeless people generally
speaking great hair great [__] here
you know
you know why they got no stress
then he's got like the [__] Chicago
cop mustache
right big [__] chest and one of those
one of those [__] jackets those
Cartwright jackets car heart Carhartt
jacket is that what they called
that's what he is from the top of the
head to the waist down he looks like he
was on the Chicago [__] police force
you know for a full [__] career
right 25 years and then from the waist
down he had on a white pleated tennis
skirt like mini skirt
with little Chris Evert like white
sneakers and socks
and just standing there like he wasn't
doing it and no one was looking at him I
started laughing and then had
immediately had like a coughing fit not
because I don't think that he should be
able to do that you know so I'm on the
right side of History I I started
laughing because everyone is sitting
there acting like what the [__] he's
doing isn't a what the [__] moment I
think a hundred percent you should be
able to do it I'm glad he did it all
right but you should be able to be you
know
there wasn't one person I mean I drove
by but there wasn't one person that kind
of looked and then you know you do that
thing we sort of walk into a tree
because you're being polite
all right let me tell you something
before you get all [__] sensitive
everybody's been that person
everybody spend that person you know one
time
one time uh
somebody I know was buying weed
it was buying weed and he was sitting in
his [__]
buddy's car the weed dealer's car back
when weed wasn't [__] legal he was
sitting there buying weed
and
and he was looking down you know he's
going down to get his money and the guy
you know was sitting there with the bag
of weed so my buddy's looking down you
know he got in his car and he was
getting the money out and he [__] the
weed dealer looked up he goes oh Jesus
Christ look at these two [__] yahoos
and he looked up and he saw me
rollerblading with another red-headed
woman
just two gingers rollerblading down the
[__] Street
and he almost [__] puked he laughed
so [__] hard and then he immediately
called me up afterwards so we've all
been that guy in the miniskirts so go
[__] yourself
um I started laughing and I went to like
a coughing fit
um
you know
it's a different world it's a different
it you know it's a different worlds and
it's always going to be changing I'm
going to go out on a limb here people I
have this Theory I think the World's
Gonna keep changing and someday that guy
when he's my age
54 and more than a half years old he's
going to be driving down the street in
his [__] uh I work for a living
jacket right
with his uh Martina Navratilova [__]
bought me it was that's what it was like
it was like a [__] Martina
Navratilova was like uh hosting like the
Letterman show back in the day when he
wore like half a suit
um
half part of me thought it must have
been a prank show or something I don't
know what anyway
um
that dude someday or whatever the proper
pronoun
um that dude's gonna be driving down the
street one day when he's my age in a
[__] Cartwright jacket a [__] mini
skirt you know he's still showing his
legs at that point you know
if you got rid of the varicose veins at
the local plastic surgeon
which you could probably do it yourself
you know they already have
do-it-yourself Studios we can record a
whole album you can't tell me in [__]
30 years when that guy's my age you
won't be able to get rid of your
varicose veins inside your house or at
least have a [__] robot do it right
um and he's gonna look because coffee
will still be here right
and he's going to look over and he's
going to see the next [__] thing and
he's gonna be in his mini skirt laughing
his fat [__] ass off going what the
[__] is going on with the world
you know
that is crazy
anyway
what am I going here
what am I doing
all right
all right I think I'm supposed to read
some ad reads now all right oh look who
it is
it's all Lindo Cheeto
wedding planning is intimidating but
finding the perfect suit shouldn't be
indochito makes it easy to get a fully
customizable suit right from home
don't goddamn suit on your big day
what the [__] is wrong with you
with dozens of high thread count Fabrics
what the [__] does that mean
and I thought that was only when you
talked about sheets I guess the more
threads it has the more it's got to be
more comfortable
hi it's redcote
that's a funny thing to say to somebody
that has a little more money than you
oh with your high thread count sheets
you [__] content
oh Mr High thread count everybody
nose in the [__] air
nobody's got more threats in his sheets
as [__] cheeks than that guy
you [__]
cozy [__]
um anyway uh what am I doing him
with dozens of high thread count Fabrics
patterns and colors to choose from
indochino helps you design a suit
perfectly tailored to your body and your
personality
dressing Grooms and groomsmen since 2007
indochino lets you design the suits
you've always wanted and fine-tune every
detail from lapels to Linings Monograms
to pocket flaps and more with suits
starting at just 4.99 and shirts
starting at just 89 bucks it's bespoke
without the premium price tag
I gotta look that what does bespoke mean
that sounds like you started a war with
your words
and then the leader of England bespoke
his ideology in the world went to [__]
tailored fit at home or in a showroom
set up your measurement profile on
indochinos website and choose your
Fabric and customizations without even
leaving the house or book an appointment
at a showroom near you and let indochino
style guides help you and your groomsmen
with every detail their team of experts
ah rubbing their chins I think we can
make a suit for this guy these their
team of experts has the resources style
advice and professionalism to make your
dream suit a reality and help your
groomsmen look as good
as good standing beside you
I'll help your Grooms and look as good
as you you know what I'm [__] looking
as good as you
you want to look the best like hey you
picked the right one you picked the
right [__] the ride lady
right off into the sunset when planning
your wedding get a suit as unique as you
with indochino go to indochino.com and
use code Burr to get 10 off
of any purchase of 3.99 or more hey if
you were unique you wouldn't be getting
married everybody [__] does it
eventually that's indochino
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code Burr
Sean John John
you know I just realized what's amazing
is I looked at that guy and that guy
like surprised me with the way he was
dressing to the point I left right but
if I saw a guy walking down if he was
holding bagpipes
you know and his skirt was had had that
[__] uh that Scottish [__] design
on and I'd be like oh look at this guy
he's getting ready for Saint Patty's Day
even though that's about the Irish but I
live in America so that's all the same
island
all right stamps.com
2023 is already well underway so don't
wait any longer to level up your small
business and set your and set your year
up for Success get ahead of the
competition by using stamps.com to mail
and ship stamps.com lets you print your
own Postage and shipping labels right
from your home or office it's ready to
go in minutes
so you can get back to running your
business sooner I'll get back to that
cocaine habit
postage rates just increased again oh
can you believe it it's almost like
they're just printing a bunch of money
with nothing behind it every August
luckily stamps.com has the best
discounts in the industry with rates you
can literally you literally can't find
anywhere else like up to 84 percent off
USPS and UPS get access to the USPS the
UPS shipping Services you need to run
your business right from your computer
anytime day or night no lines
no traffic
no waiting and if you sell products
online [__] stamps.com seemancy connects
with every major Marketplace shopping
cart usestamps.com to print postage
wherever you do business all you need is
a computer
and a prayer they'll even send you a
free scale
oh look at that you can mail out
packages and [__] do some low-level
drug dealing so you'll have everything
you need to get started
dude
what if you deal Coke and use stamps.com
and you use their scale I mean you're
already making this profit because God
knows you're not [__]
you know [__] paying taxes anyway set
your business up for Success when you
get started with stamps.com today sign
up with promo code burp Burr for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a free
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts you know it's a one-night
stand here just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the home
page and add a copper b-u-r-r
you know what's actually great about
that [__] that professional snowplow
tennis player guy that I saw is if
there's more people like that they'll be
like more people does that make any
sense of course it doesn't like that it
always feels like there's just five
groups of people there's like burnouts
right there's [__] nerds
uh this background
I'm running out of people there's not a
lot of groups
you know
what if everyone was able to be exactly
how the [__] they are
you know
do you ever think maybe it's not like
homophobia and all of this [__] maybe
it's just like the gap
you know the people that make clothes
and they're just like look in like
almost like the old a r guys whatever if
you were banned and they couldn't really
Define you they had to stick you in a
genre so they knew how to sell you
all right you got to wear your uniform
I'm coming around to this coffee shop
guy
he he's like the Miles Davis of dressing
that was like [__] Brew the clothes
it was Fusion
and I wasn't ready for it
um all right new dates for all shows
uh pre-sale starts Wednesday
do you know this is what the [__] you
know I almost went into a a
Pro drum shot that's the [__] Drum
store you want to go to out here in La
it's an absolute Legend
it's a legend like it is a legend
Jerry and all the guys down there
[__] Legends I almost went down there
today
as as a comedian father of two with no
[__] free time to even watch my
beloved my beloved Boston Bruins
um have the greatest season
of in the team's history
and almost the greatest they could
possibly have the best season regular
season ever
um
and you know what a bunch of unathletic
people are saying it doesn't mean
anything like to win a cup hey buddy you
don't mean anything you don't mean
anything how about that how about that
how about that right up your ass sorry
um right up your skirt
in case you're wearing one I'm trying to
be all-inclusive here
I almost went in there
to see if they had a remote hi-hat
yeah that's that's the amount of double
bass I've been playing lately I kind of
get that bottom [__] good times bad
times thing down I can fake it
if I do it three days in a row I I can
sound pretty good I'm talking a little
[__] here
you know for a dad
for someone who's never been paid to
play drums it's not bad
I was thinking about getting a remote
hi-hat
you know
I mean
you only live once right
I think I'm gonna get one
um I don't like my symbol so
they're too bright I want a little
[__]
darker sound
you know
to match me man because I got so many
layers no I'm sorry
I don't know I want to be interesting
all the interesting people had siljin
case when I was growing up
and all the [__] mainstream jerk-offs
that went to the mall I'll play the
Zildjian [__] A's
look at me I'm playing drums right I
suppose the other person brooding in the
corner playing [__] Dave Brubeck
a little bit buddy all right for all
shows was he a one hit wonder I don't
think he was but as far as like what
everybody remembers
um all right for all shows uh pre-sale I
got some new dates oh Billy's going back
out on the road I got another month off
ah
I could do this every year just take
three [__] months off
and just lay around like some [__]
old hound on my porch
fantastic
[__] fantastic for all shows all
right pre-sale starts Wednesday March
8th
at 10 A.M
uh local with local code local with code
Burr B 10 a.m local with code Burr bur
let me read that again pre-sale starts
Wednesday March 8th at 10 A.M local time
with code Burr b-u-r-r pre-sale ends
Thursday March 9th
uh at 11 59 PM whenever I say these
dates the early part of March I always
remember this book called Mia
um what you doing uh what you doing the
fifth of March March 5.
I kept that [__] voice message
for like a year
yeah what you doing what you doing March
the 5th of March March 5.
oh I took the gig
um all the characters you meet in this
business all right pre-sale ends
Thursday March 9th at 11 59 PM General
on sale begins Friday March 10th at 10
A.M local
all right here are the dates Sunday
April 2nd
I am in Ottawa Ontario
for the sole purpose
of going to that Ottawa Senators game
the next night
against the [__] Maple Leafs or maybe
it's the night before I don't know what
I've been trying to go to an Ottawa
Senator this game since they've been
you know around and it just never worked
out uh last time I had tickets
unfortunately Patrice O'Neal died and
that was the
you know the day of his funeral so
obviously
could go to that one so
um I'm finally getting back there
um to watch the sport that Patrice could
absolutely give a [__] about
um that's kind of funny
that he died and [__] me out of going
to a hockey game after all those years
he made fun of the game he didn't really
make fun of it that much but he was more
of a hoop guy all right south ham Hall
uh at the national Arts Center two shows
at six pm and nine pm
um and then Friday April 14th I'm gonna
be in College Station Texas at the Reed
Arena for one reason and one reason only
is that weekend I'm going to the [__]
Moto GP baby
in Austin Texas I cannot [__] wait
and last time I was in college station I
went to see Johnny Football see if he
could beat Alabama in back to back years
that was one of the loudest [__]
stadiums I've ever been to
um the most amazing first half I've ever
seen in college football they were going
bananas and then to just watch the
Alabama Crimson Tide
they came back put their foot on their
put their foot on their neck in the
second half
um
oh my God that was fun I'll tell you you
owe it to yourself if the Aggies are
good you got to go to college station
for a game those people do not [__]
around all right and then Saturday May
6th Las Vegas Nevada Dolby live
I will be there whatever Dolby live is I
will be there on May 6th sorry did I say
March 6th May 6th
um
and then let's see what else I got I got
Friday June 30th Lincoln California
Thunder Valley Casino Resort
uh Thunder Valley that sounds
intimidating uh and then Saturday August
12th I'll be in Springfield
Massachusetts at the Mass Mutual Center
tickets and information at billburr.com
tour
uh
that's exciting see that
I was six weeks into this break going
like I don't think I want to do stand up
again I I don't want to go back out on
the road and then six weeks later I'm
like yeah it's gonna be [__] fun it's
called taking a break bill you know it's
called taking care of yourself
just living your best life
um
I'm gonna go down to that coffee shop
and I'm gonna wear I'm gonna see what
[__] outfit you can wear that'll get
anybody to look
um
so he's already doing the snow plow
tennis player thing I gotta do the
I gotta think about that for a second
you know I'm actually doing this poster
on the wall vertical North North
America's civil helicopters Fleet
I uh
flew the old heli uh this weekend it's
really weird weather it was nice in the
morning shitty and then nice and I went
up there when it was shitty and for some
reason Burbank wasn't letting anybody
transition through their airspace and it
looked pretty clear to me the ceiling
didn't look that low but I don't know
I gotta ask my instructor why and so I
asked when I made the radio call
I was like uh
you know it was coming up on it and they
were like going
you know five South transition and they
were just like yeah we're not doing that
right now
it's like okay
guess I'll go back where I came from
um Little Brian Regan there for you
um
but I ended up going back
I went out the out to the west and I
just uh went out to Camarillo and I just
sort of flew the pattern landing on the
uh
the uh the pad out there and then when I
came back
you know where I've been flying out of
I'm actually looking at the helicopter
there's this [__] helicopter you got
to see this thing it's a one-seater and
I think it's the whole thing's design is
to like pick [__] up
I don't know if I'm saying it right the
common
k-a-m-a-n k1200 k-max
and
it has like two main rotor blades
right next to each other I don't know
how the [__] they don't hit each other
um it's not like the Chinook yeah the
Chinook
um well there's another one here
the camov KA 32A 11 BC it's like [__]
motorcycle so they just all name numbers
and letters where it has one two main
rotors one on top of the other
this one is like inter I don't know what
so you know those people that could do
that little butterfly thing with their
arms they bring them together and look
like they they
shut up Bill all right whatever so I go
I come back to land
and I'm landing in between like we're
just in a row like a railroad apartment
there's that helicopter where I dropped
off
towed my helipad out to and then an a
star and there was not a lot of [__]
room
and it was Wednesday
and it's just like all right I got this
i got this so what I did was I just sort
of brought the tail around and usually
what I do is I I you know I just sort of
drive it's like you're in the air but
you just sort of drive on it just as
long as you just slowly moving forward
you don't get in your own wash and you
don't have to do a bunch of [__] with
the pedals you just sort of like just
ding just set it right down but this
thing because it was so tight I
literally had to come in sideways and
then be over
my helipad so I immediately got in my
wash and it started [__] rocking back
and forth the four wheelers right there
I mean it was this was some big boy [__]
for me and I set the [__] down and I
didn't like the way it looked
and usually once I set it down I think
like well you know what I didn't total
the helicopter I didn't [__] kill
anybody let's shut it down I was like
you know what stop being a [__] she can
do better than that so I lifted it up
and then I set it down where I want it
to be I was like all right
baby steps baby steps I'm Gonna Fly
tomorrow man I can't wait
I can't wait I just hope the weather's
nice it's been um
been getting a bunch of rain out here
which is always good but then you know I
was talking to this guy today I was like
one of one of my kids
had a birthday party to go to and he
goes you know what sucks he goes all
this rain just gross [__] that's then
going to be on fire later on
it's like yeah
that is uh that is a true statement sir
all right here we go let's let's do some
reads here for this week Desert Storm
all right hey Bill comparing operation
deficit storm to a movie is appalling
shame on you I'm sure the soldiers who
fought in that war didn't feel like they
were starring in a movie
oh God that's so [__] deep
shut the [__] up I'm so [__] sick of
people getting [__] offended for
other people
you know what I mean did I mean it in an
insulting way
shame on you yeah take your shame and
shove it up your ass
[__] jerk off I'm so [__] sick of
these [__] idiots
unless he's just [__] with me shame
on you
I remember one time like when when when
that the war was first starting one of
the wars there was a guy in the NFL and
when he goes yeah Sunday's going to be a
war and then
and he had like apologize for that it's
like it's an Express
you know I wish your [__] email was
like a movie
your email was like a movie I would have
walked out on how about that
[__] jerk off all right you know what
I've been starting to do speaking of
that uh Expressions is
listening to people like me and verzie
on the verzia spec versus effect no no
that's his podcast we do the uh
the [__] is articles oh anything better
um
we uh we always give each other [__]
because we [__] up I I [__] up names he
[__] up Expressions he combines them
with other [__] so I'm just starting to
write down
I heard this guy last night at that hoop
game
you know USC was playing sloppy made a
sloppy pass through it out of bounds and
the guy behind us was saying oh that
shouldn't happen he goes you know if
that happens earlier on the year I
understand it but this time of year they
should know each other like clockwork
and I knew what he was saying but I was
just like you know when you turn your
head kind of [__] your head for a second
like yeah I don't think you said that
right
he like [__] up that expression so bad
I can't remember the right way to say it
it was running like clockwork
bam bam bam I think that's what it is
know each other like clockwork how do
you know each other like clockwork
anyway
lizard video oh I made a reference to
this
hey Billy bulbous boy you shouldn't be
talking about videos with lizards in
them when there's not actual lizards
shame on you kidding I remember that
video back in the day I believe it's
called acid lizard
uh uh no it's not called that what a
classic video I love the balloon boy and
the Walk Away part so funny anyway
here's the link no I thought it was
called something else maybe somebody
renamed it
let me see this here I think he's an
Indian
was you goddamn [__] what the [__] is
he doing
uh that's called drinking out of cups
and there was a rumor that the guy was
tripping balls and he was sitting in
his closet he was just talking to what
he was seeing and then somebody said no
that's not what happened it was I don't
know what the [__] happened but it's um
it is English but it's a bunch of words
strung together that you would you'll
never hear again
it was a moment that was captured
all right hot tubs are cool
uh hey Billy blah bag uh last month you
trash people who owned hot tubs oh God
this is just I like I gotta give a shout
out to Andrew femalis getting all the
offended people out of the way by the
way the lizard thing was obviously a
joke
um as far as saying that he was offended
okay and the rest of it was real anyways
and that's an actual video okay if
you've been on the same page okay all
right last month you trash people who
own hot tubs
that's right this has been bugging me
for a month uh you know what I love this
person already because they're admitting
that this is ridiculous you said
something along the lines that hot tub
owners are sleaze bags all right now I'm
sorry to be laughing at my own jokes but
you have to remember
that I don't remember half the [__] that
I say on this podcast all right forget
about what I say on stage I don't
remember it
I'm just going up there there's a time
I'm trying to fill up and I'm just
saying the stupidest [__] that comes in
my head and then I forget about it so I
I don't remember saying this sir
all right he says hey
I'll have you know I come from an island
in the north west coast of Scotland it's
[__] cold
okay let me try and try to do a bad
Scottish I'll have you no I come from a
night I can't do it I wish I could do a
Scottish accent
um it's [__] cold
all I can do is
bill
y goes
uh bill bull
uh I grew up in the freezing cold wind
and harsh environment environment that
drove the Scots to be the absolute nut
cases that they are today uh a few years
back I moved to London to be with my
girl you [__] sell out
you with an English girl
didn't you ever see Braveheart uh to be
with my girl and started a small
business from scratch
London by con uh comparison to Scotland
has a tropical climate is that right
I thought that that place was miserable
see I have no idea I've only been there
a few times and not for a long I went
out for a long duration same thing with
Scotland I base everything about uh
London's weather
on the beginning of uh
of sexy beast
what do you say London
or London don't make me laugh
every cat walking around with a long
face
so I just pictured it was raining all
the time London by comparison to
Scotland has a tropical climate since I
moved it has been my dream to have a
nice back garden with a hot tub and a
gas barbecue
dude you I mean if you can pull that off
in London
nobody has that [__] they're just
excited to get some [__] bread right
sorry my dream was to cook a steak for
me and my girl stew in the tub with a
cold one
watch the UFC while the bubbles tickle
my pale Scottish balls I mean you know I
would say that's that's I guess that
isn't the American dream it's
everybody's dream dude if you live in a
cold wet climate I I get it I get it I'm
sorry this actually you're making it
sound great
I really want to [__] on you but I mean
you're painting a hell of a picture here
he goes I even wear shorts outside like
I'm in Europe
I love that you guys don't consider the
fact that you're in Europe and everybody
else they are in Europe you dumb [__] I
just learned something you're like nah
nah nah that's Europe
we're Great Britain oh I love uh what's
your thread count your [__] hot tub
[__]
um I felt if I had a good looking girl
to make me laugh a couple of months at
my side in a spot in a sport to watch I
could be a happy content man dude I
gotta tell you something right now
if your dreams never get bigger than
that you're one of the wisest people
you know
on the planet
volume one is a good looking woman to
make you laugh a couple of months well
let's be honest a lot of good looking
women are funny they're too [__] hot
they walk around you know they got that
high thread count cuntiness that's my
new thing now High thread count
um a couple of months at my side in a
sport to watch I could be a happy and a
Content man there you go
maybe I could even settle down and make
some babies well
there goes the content part I mean
you'll be happy as hell but Jesus Christ
this year after seven hard years of
building my business I will finally be
able to afford this and I thought great
and I until I heard you trash my [__]
dreams on the way my way to work
get it straight
uh White British tall medium handsome
untalented man
have a can of oh sorry can a straight
white British tall medium medium
handsome talented untalented man
have anything these days dude that's
such a funny line and I butchered it
twice I apologize and maybe I am a
sleaze but I assure you that's a
complete coincidence anyway good call as
always love your [__] all of it hope to
see you live in London soon I hope to be
there soon
um dude get the [__] hot tub
he said kindest regards from the veil of
England
um get the hot tub Jesus Christ you sold
me on a hot tub
um
[__] I mean I did you probably just sold
50 000 hot tubs in Seattle
um actually we don't have those we just
turn around drinking coffee killer
whales
did I mention that I'm finally getting
into Grunge music
I did the goddamn Comedy Jam and we did
[__] we did a song I always like
sound good we did sound garden and
Nirvana and now I can't stop listening
to the [__]
and I was like maybe I'll listen to
another Nirvana song ah [__] I like that
one too you know they were the enemy
okay they killed hair metal
bastards right and then today I was at
the gym
and I heard a Pearl Jam song and I was
like God
damn it I like this one too
I want to play drums to this
[__] I'm selling out
it was us and them man it was the Sunset
Strip versus [__] Seattle man
all right killer whales uh I wasn't even
in on the Sunset Strip I would have
burned up if I was on I was in
Massachusetts in the suburbs
but you know because of that magazine
Hit Parade or I thought I felt like I
was a part of it all right killer whales
uh dear Bill kill did you hear about the
orcas that are killing great white
sharks
haven't they always been doing that a
couple killer whales showed up off the
coast of South Africa and started
killing sharks in the area known to have
many these surgic surgically Target they
surgically Target the shark's liver and
leave the rest of the body they seem to
be teaching other whales how to do the
same according to the bloke studying it
in a short span they killed 17 great
whites thought you'd be happy to hear
this I'm not happy to hear that
I want those great whites to [__]
kill people I would say the reason that
they're doing it is they're smart enough
to realize that the ocean is being
fished out
okay
and these two great Warlords there's
only room for one
wow that is fascinating
[__] fascinating
um
Jesus Christ
oh my God they they kill any more of
those Hollywood will make a movie about
it
um problem who's gonna play The Great
White and who plays the killer whale
uh problem with ginger at work what's up
you Ginger [__] hey you know if you got
a problem with the ginger you got to go
to agenda I'm telling you that's what
you got to do all right I wanted to
share an experience I've had for a
couple of years now my workplace offers
a fitness center a gym to work out in
uh if you complete 80 visits with 30
minutes durations in a year then the
company gives you a discount on health
insurance
that's amazing get off your ass you
after you work for me go [__] work
out I don't want you dying of a heart
attack and then I gotta use zip
to find somebody else all right a couple
years ago the company
direct hired a personal fitness trainer
that is fresh out of college who was
also a ginger
well I don't know what that has to do
with it you know
I'm already I'm already feeling like
you're going to be coming at us
the problem is he is oh he's a guy I
don't give a [__] about him the problem
is he has turned it into this police of
the fitness center or rather Hall
Monitor if you will
dude oh my God I swear to God I swear to
God if you take one ounce of [__]
[__]
from this [__]
power drunk [__]
this you know I've Loved all the emails
even the [__] [__] one in the first
one I've Loved all of these emails this
one this one's gonna stay with me stay
with me
all right now breathing I'm breathing I
already hate this person
um only hearing your side of the story
of course he would literally Sprint
across the gym if he sees you walk in to
log you into the computer
well it sounds like he's doing a good
job it's completely unnecessary because
they have a laptop set up to log
yourself in or he will shout hello and
Your Name Across the gym to acknowledge
that you are there
ah you're a miserable [__] you want to
be left alone you need to communicate
that this is this has nothing to do with
this guy and it's just not me defending
him because he's a fellow Ginger this is
you dude and I gotta tell you I am way
more you than that other [__] guy
often he will guard the door as you walk
in
say some really awkward one-liners like
hey you coming and going
this dude's just [__] He's this is
just he has personal trainer energy
they got to be upbeat anyway meaning are
you just starting your 12 hour shift or
getting off your 12-hour [__] shift he
will ask that on a daily basis we'll cut
him some slack he's just out of [__]
College anyway now you can imagine when
when covet hit I already know the
solution to this
he took it to an extreme and Next Level
being the masked police and also
cleaning thing obsessively even after
the person using the machine just
cleaned it
I mean he probably was told to do this
this kid's just doing a good job you're
a miserable [__] and I I'm a miserable
[__] so I'll get you out of this I.E he
says putting sanitize sanitizing wipes
in each hand and getting on his hands
and knees and vigorously rubbing the
rails on each side of the the treadmill
belt I mean Hey listen everybody says
these young kids don't want to work this
kid's crushing it I don't want the
problem is he said I can respect this
kid's work worth it I think there you go
in wanting to do a good job but he needs
to learn that some people just want to
go to the gym in a Zone mindset of
busting out a good workout and not
socializing or bullshitting exactly
but he's not a mind reader buddy what
you're going to have to do is [__]
grow a pair and go up to the young
Ginger and tell him that and not in a
[__] way
all right
and I love that you've waited too long
to say this that now it's going to be
awkward so I gotta I gotta think of the
way you need to say it anyways he says
especially before after 12 hour shift
you being a person that goes to a gym I
would think you you too would understand
this don't try to stay
boat
when the [__] do I work a 12-hour shift
I don't have the real job
um I know it's just not my hatred for
people because yeah there we go there we
go hatred of people because I've asked
other co-workers about how they feel
about the kid and they agree he's a
major pain in the ass how do I defuse
this
all right there's two ways to do this
you could see the humor in it and try to
out energy him
um or what you do is you just go up to
him and just say listen
um
I really respect your worth ethic and
you have an amazing positive attitude
but I gotta be honest with you man I'm a
curmudgeon okay I like to keep to myself
when I come down here I go into a Zone
and I I don't want anybody talking to me
is there any way I know you see me I
respect that you see me and all it's
just any way you could just like just
leave me alone when I come in here would
would just make my day
that last part sucked but the beginning
part was good and you know what to say
my problem it's your [__] problem
all right I can tell you this
you hit the nail on the head here you
went to a ginger and a curmudgeon I I
relate to both people in this story this
is like a it's like a good movie
um
yeah
he could just be like dude dude it's
early it's early
but do you think that he's going to be a
little rat fink little Kami Pinko and
he's gonna [__] rat you out
if you say that
you could be a total [__] when he comes
running hey
you could say get a new joke
see you don't want to do that that's
what you're gonna do because it's
building up in you
you're gonna snap dude
but you know something you you're you're
evolving as a person because you're
asking how do I defuse this
how do I defuse this what the [__] is
that
oh
I know what that is there's nothing I
don't know how to [__] hook up sorry
my [__]
I gotta clean this [__] place out I
literally have foot pedals underneath
when I was going for my instrument
rating
[__] things just fell on my foot
um
yeah this isn't it nice as possible way
just be like dude I'm actually envious
of how excited and amped up you are
every day to come in here all right but
I got to be honest with you man uh you
know
I I'm just I'm not built like you I'm a
really quiet
stay to myself kind of person if there's
any way I don't you know give that
energy to everybody else I don't I don't
need it I don't need it I just want to
put my headphones on and work out can
you do that for me I really appreciate
thanks bro just do that
that's what you have to do that's what
you have to do or you could go to a
different gym
you know but then I won't get credit for
waking up
um well that's the price you got to pay
all right that is the podcast everybody
God bless you you jacket your mini skirt
whatever the [__] you're wearing uh God
bless that DJ at the USC gang you play
just enough to keep the young people
interested but not pissed off a
curmudgeon like me hey I want to ask the
curmudgeon at the gym what do I say to
these DJs at the games
with a plane like I'm telling you I'm
calling this right now there's an NBA
player is going to get tinnitus from
playing in the [__] League how loud
that music is it's like going to a
concert every single [__] night 82
concerts in a year
and that's not if they don't even make
the playoffs and they're going to get
tinnitus and they're going to sue the
league I'm calling that right now or
somebody works security at a uh at an
arena it's gonna [__] happen and
that's a dangerous one too that's a
dangerous one because you can't [__]
prove it
you know a buddy of mine said that that
you know when cops want to get workman's
comp that's what they say they when they
shoot their gun in the line of service
and they just don't want to do it
anymore they'll just say I got tinnitus
because you can't [__] prove it yeah
see that
I'm [__] I don't know what I'm doing
on this podcast now I'm I'm bringing up
[__] scenarios and I don't think you
can handle it man no all right whatever
I should enter the podcast before that
but I did